Male: This introduction to lithography
will show the artist's drawing process,
materials that are used on drawing
a lithographic stone,
the process of printing,
and the details and subtlety
that can be achieved
in the printing process, as well as
a close-up look at prints themselves.
Lithography, or stone
printing, is an intricate
printmaking process that revolves around
grease and water resisting one another.
An artist will draw with a greasy material
on a lithographic stone.
Once we've established a
drawing, or grease, on the stone,
we chemically treat the
stone with materials
like gum arabic to establish the areas
where water goes; rosin and
talc, to help us through
what we call an etch, or it's basically
to establish the drawing
down inside the stone.
Once the grease is pulled into the stone
we can replace the drawing material
with any colored greasy
ink that we would like.
The basic drawing materials that we use
from a historic standpoint
are things like lithopencils.
It's a pencil and it's
in this sort of format.
The lower the number, the greasier
and waxier that material is.
If you want a fine hard line, you use
a higher number because
that's a harder material.
Lithographic crayons are in this format.
The suface of a lithocrayon
is such that you can
use it for rubbing or for a fine line
and it can be shaped,
also, to fit your needs.
They come in varying sizes
and hardnesses as well.
The surface of a lithographic stone is
a very seductive surface to draw on.
It's responsive and it's also sculptural.
Because the stone in and of
itself is receptive to water,
so if I dampen the stone
it absorbs the water,
and it's also receptive to grease,
which means it will
suck the grease down in.
It allows me to put drawing material down
and then remove it with
things like razorblades,
an X-ACTO knife, sandpaper, so it allows
you to draw in a more
sculptural way rather than
having the limitations
of a piece of paper.
This is a lithographic
stone with a drawing
by artist Steve Johnson on it.
It was a drawing done
with a lithographic crayon
directly on the surface of the stone.
This stone is made from limestone.
It is completely open, as we call it,
which means it's receptive to grease
and water at this state.
If I were to put my thumbs
on the surface of the stone,
that would become image area
because of the grease from my skin.
It's a fairly delicate drawing surface
from that standpoint,
but it's also a positive
in the sense that every fine mark that you
can put down with a greasy material
will hold in that fidelity.
In this process it's
what's called a first etch,
and right after that we will
remove the drawing material
and apply printing ink to it,
which is what's called proving the stone.
Now the drawing material
has a small amount of talc
and rosin attached to it,
and it's ready to be etched.
We first apply the gum
arabic to the stone.
This is to start to establish
the non-image area of the stone.
What we're trying to make sure is that
the whites of the stone stay that way
and they receive gum
arabic, which will help
them receive water later on.
Once the stone has begun to receive
the gum into it, we
can apply the acidified
gum arabic in this case, which is TAPEM.
That acidification with
tannic acid helps keep
that gum arabic permanently
bonded to the stone.
I'm also being very gentle at this point
as to not scrub or disturb the drawing
material that's on the stone.
Once I've etched the stone,
I'll remove some of that material
and replace it with fresh gum arabic.
This is what we call
cooling the stone down.
It's basically reducing the quantity
of acid on the surface of the stone,
so that when we buff in the gum arabic
into a very thin and even sheet,
we don't run the risk of having
too much acid remaining on the stone.
We use cheesecloth to
buff this in very evenly.
Next, we'll be washing this drawing
material out with lithotine.
It's a greasy solvent, which
is a refined turpentine
made specially for lithography.
The drawing material will be replaced
with asphaltum, which
has also been thinned
with lithotine, to create a greasy,
very [anchor]-receptive base for the ink
on the roller to replace it with.
At this point, your
drawing will disappear.
It's not actually gone,
and what you can see
is a residue or a ghost
image as we call it
there on the surface of the stone.
That is where the stone is being converted
to soap, or oleo-manganate of lime.
Right now, when we buff the asphaltum
down onto this, we're going to replace
that drawing material, which is in effect
grease sticking to grease.
It's the grease-loving area of the stone,
or the oleophilic area of the stone
accepting new grease.
When a stone has been etched properly
you'll be able to see a fairly clear
ghost image on the surface of the stone.
What will be happening next is that
we are going to wet the
surface of the stone.
I will go over it with a
wet towel and a dry towel.
Kate will sponge that surface
and I will apply ink
immediately to the stone
and that will bring up our image.
(roller sounds)
In the beginning, we're not actually
interested in transferring ink to paper.
We're actually more interested in forcing
ink into the stone so that
it can start to fill up
the greasy reservoir where it was.
Yeah, go ahead, Nance.
You can see only a very
small amount of ink
has actually been
transferred because we're
starting to push ink into the stone first.
It's an average of four to six newsprints
for any given particular stone
to come up to a full inking.
When printing on a
dampened sheet of paper,
we can achieve a different tonal range
based on the softness of that paper.
What we want to do is match that
movement and flow of the hand.
What I'm looking for when I look at this
is to see if it feels as if a hand
has moved across that surface with
a drawing material.
If it has and if it
maintains that character,
then I would consider
that a good impression.